hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the 2020 chasuble Masters
where a nipple and giri are brawling it
out to see who will will get the chance
to challenge Magnus in the final so this
is the second game of their second match
first game was won by Giri so either
wins the second match as well it's game
over for Nepal and he will of course try
to win the second match and then force a
third one so this is a game - game 1 was
a draw let's see what what happens here
so nip opens with Knight to f3 he goes
for the red tea and Aggie replies with
the d5 we have III night to have sex and
now C for challenging the center with
east six and now we could see a lot of
ideas here maybe d4 just a standard
stuff but here b3 preparing the finca
tatin get to the dark square bishop so
c5 by giri and now comes the Bishop to
b2 so both words fighting for the d4
square Knight to c6 preparing d4 and
here we have a trade we have C
characters each characters and Bishop to
e2 and here as an epilogue that Giri
does go for d4 and this is not new it
was played before for example a Nakamura
defeated Engler and with Bishop to b5 in
this position in the 2019 Code of our
blitz tournament in Abidjan but here we
have captures on d4 so going for the
trade and it's still not a new position
C captures on d4 is a known known move
was played in the match Daniel du Bois
verse 11 Aragon in the 2018 Summer
Theater book world blitz championship
but here we have Knight captures on d4
and now it is already as of MOVEit that
we have a completely new game
so Gary goes to the unexplored territory
Neto castles and Bishop to e7 Gary just
prepares the castle he doesn't mind a
trade in the center so never goes for it
we have Knight captures seek actress and
now Bishop to f3 making it a bit
difficult for black to develop the Queen
side due to this upon being under attack
so here give it just castles and rook to
b8 now sorry first rook to e1 of course
and then rook to b8 you cannot play
twice in a row and now preparing your
b5 so here we have Knights to a3 now
with ideas of bringing the night over to
c4 so b5 this prevents the idea and now
if you want to go night the c2 let's say
you try to go after the d4 pawn it's not
really a problem since Bishop to c5
defends it and all is well here for
black so instead after b5 nipple goes
Queen to e 2 he goes after the bishop
here and now rook to e8 adjust defense
and now does threaten some nasty
discoveries like Bishop captures an a3
so Queen to b3 nipple use this maneuver
to get the Queen over here to get a
double attacking on the pawn and now
Geary eliminates the knight and a3
getting the attention away from the d4
pawn so Bishop captures and now Bishop
the b7 offering a trade of light square
bishop as well we are group capture
Sonny eight Queen captures and now at
Bishop to c5 here nipple could grab the
pawn right away however this allows
Geary to just open up his King side with
captures captures and well it is it is a
bit of a bit of an issue
ya know I mean the computer says it's
okay but if you're a human and it's a
rapid game you kinda don't want to have
your structure now I destroyed like this
in front of the in front of the enemy
King so here Bishop to c5 you can always
catch it capture it later and now you're
attacking this point and this bone so
black will not be able to defend against
both red so here Giri goes Bishop
characters on f3 Queen captures and now
Queen e5 now guarding and attacking but
now comes Bishop captures on a7
so the rock is under attack we have
looked at eiated giving out threatens
Quinta e1 which would result in mate
after rook captures and delivers made so
h3
creating some breathing room for the
king we have h6 Aguirre does the same
and now well seems like a reasonable
idea to go a 4 here a4 creates a passed
pawn for white and it of course is one
of the options for white but then black
has something like b3 opens up an attack
on the rook and after the Queen defends
it now you can go captures captures and
it's still still a very nice position
for a white you have a passed pawn
however nipples
I can do much better so he first goes to
rook the c1 and we have Queen to b6
Geary makes it a bit difficult for an
effort to go for any sort of a rook lift
because if you try something like this D
H 2 square is still covered rook to e1
just delivers checkmate so instead we
have brushed back the c5 pushes Girish
Queen back Queen to d7 and now Queen to
d3 again with a double attack on the
pawn here and well you could play
someone like rook c8 try to try to
create some some pins here but before
just takes care of everything you can
just move the rook next whoa move the
rook on the next move
and then you can either pick up this
point or this point depending on a word
black place so after Queen d3 giri goes
for the very interesting knife that
efore he wants to give up this pawn but
pick up the d2 pawn in the end and the
point is if you go for the pawn right
away let's say captures then Black has
the option of going just captures here
and after characters and c5 now the
Queen can capture and d2 so it's not as
great like still you get to the past
pawn characters captures but nepo is
convinced he can do much better than
this even though this is this is also
very very nice so instead after Knight
to e4 nipple goes Bishop to b6 he says
I'm gonna capture on the next move and
not allow Knight captures on c5 so
that's how I'm gonna do it and the giver
says ok I'm still gonna capture on beat
you with the Knights Oh Queen d6 attacks
the bishop so forces the trade and here
Queen captures and b4 Queen captures and
b5 is also a possibility but never goes
for Queen captures and d4 instead we
have Queen captures Bishop captures and
now we we get this position where it's
six points against two which is pretty
much winning for white however Gary
decides he's gonna snatch the d2 pawn
and try to try to survive whatever comes
however this doesn't work and of course
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure out why it doesn't work and have
that title of the video in mind while
you ponder on the position so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting which pawn
push is all it takes and for those of
you who just want to enjoy
so it's actually f3 and the point is now
the night has no escape squares so all
of the squares are covered by something
and there is no way to get the night out
of harm's way
so here Rock to eat to buy Giri he will
try to do it and maybe try and do some
some tricks but bash up the C 3 we have
Quinta h7 he brings the king in 3rd game
but now there is well the night is under
attack it has nowhere to go
the only thing that's left is to attack
it twice and then the game is over and I
hope none of you were considering Roxy
too because if you do this there's night
captures and if three truck loses the
rook so a good job I'm not thinking
about that
so rook to d1 this is the way to do it
you go after the night this way and now
the night is just trapped so here giri
gives up the night for for at least some
pawns G characters in rookie 3 now we
have Bishop the e1 and he picks up d f3
pawn now rook the d5 never says ok you
have that one I'm gonna grab this guy
and the two connected passed pawns plus
the bishop are more than enough for a
victory so looked at e3 he goes after
the bishop King F 1 we have worked to f3
with check but now Bishop to f2 and now
again he doesn't want to give out the b4
pawn so Geary pushes it but now rook the
d4 nipple goes after it so now we have
captures on h3 captures than before and
now g5 and well now giri of course is
also ready to push his past pawns but
nepos past points are much faster so
just a 4 and here Gary play rook to h1
check but here of course nepo doesn't
move the King and allow something like
rook day 1 instead he just goes rook to
g1 and it was in this position on move
39 that uh nigiri resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you're down a whole piece and there's
just not nothing you can do about this
and this is only game 2 so now if it was
game forward maybe Gary booth would try
to you know play it out all the way
however it's only game 2 and Gary I
resigned however game 3 and 4 were also
drawn which means that never wins match
2 and
we will definitely have a match 3 so
Gary won the first match on April 1 the
second match and now today we are going
to have the third match which we are
also going to cover to see who will face
Magnus Carlsen in the finals so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Elvis Marrero
Rosales Khan Zachary wolf Chris Picard
and Michael Hildebrand for her
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
Finkle for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of the 2020
testable masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day